From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Are we rolling? Good morning. Good morning. It's December 6, 2015. I'm Emily Crosby and we're in Jackson, Mississippi with worth long.
And John Bishop is filming and we're here with the Civil Rights History Project which is co-sponsored by the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum on African American History and Culture.
Thanks for joining us this morning. Great to be here.
Could you tell us when and where you were born and about your family and community?
Right. I was born worth Westinghouse Long J.R.
In Durham, North Carolina, born at Duke Hospital in January 15, 1936.
My mother Gertrude Watson Long, my father, Reverend William Worth Long.
We're both North Carolinians. My father, born over in New Charlotte in Mecklenburg County and my mother, born in Chatham County, which is basically from Durham about 30 miles.
And a center of where he as a presiding elder in the African Methodist Fiscal Zion Church had at least 10 churches.
One of the things that he did was he was as a circuit rider was that he went from church to church.
He had what he called quarterly conferences. And at these conferences which he scheduled regularly, he would do the business of the church.
And the business of the church at that time was broad.
It included what they call general claims, you know, the financial aspects, the mortgages, the membership, foreign, I almost said foreign aid, but missionary funding, especially for Africa at that time.
And youth development, all of that within one church element.
And my mother, complimented his work. Not as a secretary, but as an administrator.
As an administrator, she helped manage the financial aspects, not just of the home, but of his church, of this broad spectrum of network, with an African Methodist Fiscal Zion Church, AME Zion Church.
And I used to, she would sometimes talk about her early upbringing, as would he, but always in different settings.
My father would talk about it when he took me out to work me to death on the farm.
And he would, if we were doing work that, that was close work, where we could talk, like he had a role and I had a role, then we could talk across the role.
But generally, he was behind the meal. We had a farm just five miles from Durham that was, that supplied us with milk.
And all about garden needs, garden food needs.
Ask me a couple questions.
Yeah. So, would you, if it's providing you milk, you have to go back and forth every day, or if people are helping with...
No, my father, for five days a week, got up in the morning, got into his jeep and drove out to the farm.
And stayed all day and came back at night. He came back in time for dinner. We waited for him in many cases.
And then we would eat our last meal.
But we're only talking about five miles away. On the weekends, one of his sons, in fact his own son, worth W, would get on his bicycle and pedal out with a hand.
With a milk hand and milk the cow. And feed the hogs, the two hogs, and feed the mule.
And then pedal with carefully, with the milk. In fact, I could almost turn the milk, depending on the roads that I drive home.
Come back and weather the road.
Right. But the milk had a five-night mile journey.
Did you enjoy it when you and your father would work so hard to talk?
I did indeed. I liked it when he would not be formal. My father, as a preacher, had a formal aspect.
But he was a great storyteller and had a great sense of human. But when he got formal, I think he thought formal.
But his expressions were folk. He had folk expressions. He was what you know. He was known as a country preacher.
So he was what you call a shouting preacher, a shouting stomping preacher. And folk used to say in the African mode.
And of course my father was a head the head the head the lineage, the African lineage in the sense that
he married his first wife, he married from Nigeria. They were free Africans.
As I looked through Cardiff G. Witton's book on free Negroes, what I recall, her family, her entire family, according to the census, were free.
But we cannot ascertain in our day off county North Carolina when they were freed. My father was almost adopted by that family when his folk in Mecklenburg County passed.
And the family that had taken them in basically pledged their oldest daughter to him. Her name was Clara. But she died.
So then he married the second daughter, the second most biological daughter, Minnie. And so Minnie Banger, long, was her name.
And entering into that marriage, my father who then went to seminary in South Carolina took his wife and her mother as part of that marriage.
And he went for a year as I understand it to hood theological seminary in South Carolina. And there's a school there called Livingston College. And in fact that was a school that I think he planned for me to go to.
But that's another story.
In going to his first church in Chatham County, North Carolina, Mitchell Chapel Church in Pittsburgh, North Carolina, when they arrived from Southbury,
it's my understanding that the church had provided a posse that had a dirt floor. And his wife shook her head, but her mother picked up a made a broom and started sweeping.
And at that time you could get straw grass and just wrap it, wrap it, made a broom and started sweeping. And that sealed a deal.
And he was on that district for over 30 years. He passed into the church for just a year or so and then became a full time for that in L.D. of the Durham district of the AME's I'm sure.
So both your parents, so eventually your father will be married.
My father, after the death of many his first wife, he married Gertrude Watson, who also, whose husband had died in a manning accident in Chatham County. And who had three daughters.
My father by that time had two daughters. And so in this marriage, my mother, everybody called her Aunt Gertrude, my mother had gotten a settlement of a nice settlement for that time and was able to buy a house in Durham with a
duplex. And she rented out one side and they lived in the other. So she was considered doing pretty good, especially since both of them had gone as far as they could in school out in the country and got, I think, six grades. I think that was the maximum that you could get at that time.
She had worked in Liget and Myers factory after the death of her husband as a cleaning up. But then she had worked for part of the Duke family as a cook and as a household domestic.
And she was very good at that because she entertained for my father when the bishop came or when dignitaries came, when people from the NAACB came and had a later time, Bishop Spots would.
I knew almost all of the officials within this African church. Right. Her brother, her stepbrother had been a bishop in that church and was assigned to the Liberia.
The new new bishops went to the missions and when he came to Mount in Durham, he had a palmato.
That's what we call a palmato, but it was a palm, a gold palm attack clip. They had a box up. I mean a small box up. They would just go play the duplex. And I remember, he gave me one.
I couldn't believe it. And I stuck it in one of my best ties. Of course it ruined my tie because the thing was handmade. The point of it was, so I had this mixed feeling.
Not about Africa or not about my uncle, but about the technology about the technology about this gift that cost me a tie. And I always remember that.
Bishop E.B. Watson was his name. Now other people visited us. In fact, I've been asking my family whether Ella Baker came through with the NAACP. There's a man about a name of Barnes who was with the NAACP. And we'll get to that.
And that, of course, later, Alex Barnes, who headed the paper for the Amizan Church, it's called the... I can't do that right now. But Barnes came by with more than one person from the NAACP to sit at our Gertrude's table.
Which, right, Alex Barnes. And I heard many times. I heard them, you see, I was in the living room. I could hear them talking about different things. And they were talking about the business of the church in some cases. But mostly they were talking about the plate of Africans in the world.
And about people in the plate of the pool in the world. So they separate. But what I'm trying to do here is to understand that they had a world consciousness. But they had also an African consciousness.
They had some a root consciousness. That's what I'm talking about. And this is not in some political... This is a cultural religious aspect, I think. But it was deep down.
So both of your parents had country roots?
Both came from rural backgrounds. They came to Durham.
Durham and the whole question of, there's a saying that you can take black folk from the country. But you can't take the country from black folk.
They said that proudly. Right, they said it a little different day. Right, but they said it.
I'm trying to help you in that country. Bling things up.
So later, I would use that. I said, you can take the African from Africa. But you cannot take the African.
The African.
Right.
How did you talk about the difference between the country and Durham and how that interconnections and...
And also as it relates to higher income, higher social status, we lived in a house that we inherited in a sense.
We had heard of the mortgage from my mother's sister, who's husband worked in Long Island in a assembly plan.
And they had purchased this house in a place where they were going to build a college north-growing central university.
So people were building houses in that area. And it was on a place called Fomosa Street. Well, within a few months, people who were going to be at the college and who envisioned a different kind of community came in.
And with architect, text, build their homes on what they renamed Fomosa Avenue.
They were on Fomosa Avenue. And my house in the center was made of lumber. But these houses were brick and stone. Right.
This is not to tell the three little wolves. But on my left, not your Harris. He on an insurance company across the street, Mr. Henry McKinley-Machal.
And insurance company, the vice president of the college, Dr. A. L. the across the street from me, next to him, who first and then became president of North Fine Mutual Life and joined.
The Chamberlain studio, music studio, a piano studio, where all the kids in the community from whatever background came in and learned how to play the piano from Mrs. Sharon, who was a daughter to CC Spall and who founded the North Fine Line of Mutual Life Insurance Company.
And an architect, a construction person in the next house, Mr. what doesn't matter. And the head of the bank in the next.
This community, when I describe it, for instance, people say, oh, you, you, you went in a great community. Immediately.
Now, this was the kind of community that I had to grow up in.
How can I say some people move into a high-class neighborhood. But in your case, the high-class neighborhood came up.
And we were not well-heated. You know, we didn't have a lot of resources at that time. And we, of course, everybody on that block sent their kids to not just private schools.
They sent them to Palmer Memorial Institute. At least for high school. Right. And some was when I was working out in the field. They sent them to camp at water. And Massachusetts. So they were a part of this, of, of, of, they were in a different world.
I, Durham was considered one of the, like, the financial center for Black America at that time.
At that time, right. And the most important element in their, in terms of education was not just the college. It was the business school.
Started by a woman who realized that, that, that, that, in order to run a business, you had to have workers who, who were competent and who understood, you know, how to do accounting and how to do typing and correspondence.
And my sisters went to North Carolina College. But most of the employees for North Carolina Mutual went to the Durham Business School. And of course, she was a member of my father's church. So, I was going to be really, it doesn't have the same kind of income. You have the farm and you've got the church.
And you don't have the same kind of education, although I have a world, the awareness and clearly skill. Right. So do you feel a part of this community? Do you feel a separation?
I did at a certain point. I remember that my mother had a garden in the back. And she said she wanted me to come in and bring in a wagon load of manure from the farm.
And I was trying to figure out how can I do that? I ended, and what should I do at late at night, early in the morning before the day? Because that was going to be embarrassing to me.
So I took off early in the morning. I used to throw papers at 5.30 and get up at 5.30 and throw papers in the morning. But I rode my bicycle in the dock.
I went out to the farm. The wagon was ready. You know, I hooked up the mule.
I drove speedily to the city line and on these paved streets, passed the college into Formosa, Avenue.
And then I'm galloping and trying to get into my driveway. And the women come out, Mrs. Michelle and others come out on their porch and say, can we get somebody that fly all guy? Can we get somebody that fly all guy?
It's like somebody had cell phones and told him what I was going to do. But then once that happened, I was valued in the community.
I'm not going to say what you're saying.
And we shared a, if we kill hogs, sometimes my father would come and put a hog on the back of a trailer behind his jeep and pull it into the bag.
He would divide it up and package it and give it out in the community. He would share it in the community.
I mean, the howl in the hall. We're talking about Tim LaLine. He didn't give them the hooves and the chidnets and the snout.
I feel good in my community. I feel bad, but not just for that. People seem to like my work ethic. I took papers from the time I could carry the bag.
I get up early in the morning and...
So even though it's a kind of elite class, the community in the black world are good work ethic.
Very valuable. And then at that time I had to collect also on the weekends. So I had an interaction with people in a way I never would have.
And they would counsel me every time, every stop, a little lecture, a little piece of advice, you know.
And then your money, not that.
It's supposed to be saying, you make it right.
It's like a commercial. I said, I said, I mean, I listened to little tidbits of advice from people. But mostly good.
In fact, I use some papers in the school. Some of it folk. A little folk saying and stuff.
But most of it having to do with success.
If you work hard, the whole thing, if you put your nose to the ground and stone, if you...
You can make it. And that was the ethic.
Very little interaction with anybody other than the black community.
Because I lived on the edge of HATA, H-A-Y-T-I, HATA. And this community was self-sustaining.
Two, you know, black-on theaters. The Bill Moore Drug Store.
The hotel over the drug store. The theaters, the Riatto and the Book of Tea.
A service printing company. A printing company. I mean, in the same area.
The reason I could catalog it in this way is that I took papers to everybody, you know, in that area.
So it's just like in my memory bank, is that entire community?
Right. I can do it. Even though the doors are no longer there. They had opened. Are there?
You mentioned different people from the church and the NAACP coming and sitting at the table and house.
And your families and churches connections to Africa. And NAACP. And you said that the church, there was a lot of business of the church.
Business of the church, yeah.
So what are some of the things that your father and then your mother with them emphasized in terms of the church and the community?
What were the things that they were trying to do? What was their vision?
Well, we called it up, the, you know, community uplift.
And they are saying, and they didn't just articulate it. They practiced it.
So, for instance, when young women who were required to live on campus, when the girls, so-called girls' dormitory got filled up.
And they had to live on campus or they had to live with a relative or someone certified.
So, I grew up during, I can't remember the years, with as many as eight young women in my house.
Between your sisters?
For four, four, yes. And the college students.
I must have been once. For my man.
I was happy. I felt valued.
In my community, in my household.
Of course, again, the encouragement, but also the commercial and the lecture.
Everybody always had something to say, but at the same time they had, they pointed you in a certain kind of direction.
Did you do your homework?
What did you do?
Right. They tried you out in mathematics.
My next, next to my next door neighbor was the German professor of languages, Doc Holmes.
He would come back and he would speak German.
And I would, I didn't know what the hell leaves. I said, why is he cussing me?
And he would, he would just continue it.
The next day he come back, he'd say something in French.
And so finally, I said, well look, I'm a had, I'm a go up and ask this man, what are you trying to do?
Right. So, it was about Christmas.
And he came in, he said, he started singing, Oh, for a tree.
In German.
And I said, what are you doing?
And he said, look, come on, let's sing.
He said, I'm going on down to the house.
And he said, well, let's sing.
And then you can walk on back.
And so I learned how to listen and and and pronounce.
I learned some German on that occasion.
But also I got a friend, Mr. Holmes was also in charge of the, the last exam program.
So when Marion Anderson came to town, he had there enough seats.
He would send me on up to the balcony and say, wait a minute, some seats in the balcony.
And Paul Robison, I mean, some fantastic, a Philippa Scherler, a pianist, a young African American pianist.
These are things that I actually miss myself.
Over Northland Central, in the last exam program here.
But the reason I started doing it was that he had first let me into the basketball games.
And the football games.
And then this dude was pretty smart.
And then he let me go to the last exam.
He told my mother, you know, it'd be good if he comes into to this program.
So I saw all of the major classical talent of the day there at Northland Central.
It opened a whole new realm to me.
I'm going to mess with your work.
Okay, that's fine.
Can I pull it off?
Yeah, he can.
Just the clouds a little bit.
That's good.
Yeah, I'd probably put it on backwards.
Great. Thank you.
Yeah.
You want to sit the water?
No, I think not.
I better leave well enough of mom because I'm finally coming into where I can talk.
I'm going to put it down on my foot.
I'm going to put it down there.
Okay, that's good.
I just said I moved it.
I want to do it.
Right, so we're going to go on.
One of the first things who came and sat at our table was Floyd McKissie, a young attorney.
At that time, I knew him because he practiced taught and taught me civics at the school.
He had applied to go to University of North Carolina and University of North Carolina.
Built a law school rather than accepted him.
They built a law school, right?
Just in front of the most avenue, I'm serious.
The first year they used the old science building.
But by the next year, the state of North Carolina, rather than accept a black man in the law school, built an entire law program at North Carolina Central University.
What did you think about that?
What?
I thought that I probably would have more people apply for different kinds of diverse programs.
And get more programs.
The question of integration at that time was not one of my major concerns.
My concern was having access to something that could prepare you for life.
So that was my attitude.
But it was absurd.
Everybody at my high school, hillside high school, in Durham, North Carolina, had a master's degree.
Most of them had received it as a subsidy from the state of North Carolina.
Rather than accept them at one of the white universities, they paid them to go to the University of Chicago to go to Columbia University.
I mean, they actually paid them.
So I would think about it in a different way today.
But that was...it shows you the absurdity.
It seems to me of the system.
Of just how...
How you'll conceive it is, right?
What are some of the other ways that you encountered first in Caled Race?
Well, I tell the story about how I would drive with my father.
It was legally...
One of his...he was driving with one eye.
So he would...
On his weekend, check-up meetings, he would take off from Durham, go through Chapel Hill,
to these different ten churches.
And very often, you know, if I were not playing ball or doing whatever it was, I would go with him.
But as a young man, as a young boy, when I went with him, he'd have to stop for gas.
And he would...I remember in the wartime, he got special ration stamps because he was a minister.
And because he was an evangelist minister, so that he had to go...
He would stop and I remember being stopped at one place near Chapel Hill,
but almost to Chatham County.
And a young boy came out...
The only son of this filling station.
And he looked at my father and my father had on this hat with a three-piece suit,
all black and a fairly decent looking car.
And he looked at him and he didn't...
I don't think he kind of figured what to call him.
So then what you would do in that case is you could say, preach it.
And you know.
But you wouldn't say, sir.
So he got it right.
He said, preach it.
I said, should I fill it up, preach it?
He said, yes.
And then my father continued to talk to him and build him up.
And so finally, the kid washed his windshield.
It's on the herd of...
The kid washed his windshield and weighed.
So I learned it may be two things.
This is someone who had not had the black experience.
Right.
But he at least was able to build a human relationship at a peer level at that time,
of that time, of a peer level at that time, at that level, at that time.
And I learned from that.
But it taught me two things.
Because I tensed up when he was having trouble trying to decide how to address my father.
But after a few times with different experiences and different styles,
my father, people would sometimes say, sir, it's a little different.
Because of his respect for him and of the respect that he had for himself.
He had that courage.
It taught me something about self-image, about how you see yourself, how others see you,
and how you then you can see them in good light.
But not through...
But only through engagement.
Only through engagement.
We try to do things that are theoretical.
We try to have conversations.
Right.
Let's have conversation.
But change, I think, comes from engagement.
Right.
Yeah.
I think Floyd, Floyd McKissick was our family lawyer.
Later our family lawyer, because he was in a little local hero to me.
And he would get in class and he would...
He also had nationalist ideas...
As a young age.
At a young age when he was a practice teacher.
Right.
And he was not just...
They were...
Our families were close and we were in the same congregation also.
So he was a little...
He and his sister.
He's an important employee.
I mean, yeah.
I think McKissick was a very, very important...
And he eventually becomes chair of court or...
He became the chairman of court, yeah.
What do you remember about the end of Lacey Peer?
How did you...
You know, the father's relationship with the end of Lacey Peer and the father's...
We're going to have a chapter in every church unless there are two churches in a town.
And then we must have at least one chapter in each of our churches within my district.
And the Durham district was the largest district within the African-American...
Within the AME's Andrews.
It's a major district.
Mostly because of its numbers, but also because of its...
I can't believe it.
Yes it is.
So you were talking about your father and his churches in the end of Lacey Peer?
Right.
And how the church was not removed from the community.
It was a center.
And this was not just true of my father's church.
In the networking within the African-American community in North Carolina...
And those who have studied Alabama, they know the relationship between the church and the community...
Between the educational institutions and the community.
Between the business aspects and the community.
But in a real sense, in some churches, people can ban those elements.
And my father believed in that.
That you sponsor education, that you sponsor economic development.
Right.
And self-sufficiency.
He would go to the courthouse and buy land that had been mortgageed and resell it.